welcome back to new rockstars it is now
time to move on to some uh more
bite-sized questions and we got some
mailed submissions this week so uh
hit me yeah i've got the questions here
but i went ahead and forwarded the mail
to you oh you did
hold on so i wouldn't have to touch on
nothing yeah well oh oops
too late so first up i have uh from
cal n su what is gamora's sword god
slayer made of
it can kill as guardians can it kill
celestials
would thor [ __ ] up with god slayer and
never have needed to go get stormbreaker
uh philip when you open your mouth a
little bit there i just heard like a
tone i have no idea what you said
um because we do all of our own
censoring ourselves now during this
quarantine period anyway i assume you
said
okay well godslayer is one of the most
powerful weapons in the marvel universe
um its substance is undefined but
in the mcu we know of four interesting
metals that are fictional so we have uru
number one uh we have vibranium uh
two there's adamantium which i don't
think has been introduced in the mcu yet
but we know it's coming
and then yaka that's what um yondu's
arrow is made out of um
so we know gamora used the god slayer to
kill the obelisk
all their other weapons weren't working
that's the one thing that did uh but
when she tried to use the
uh dagger that was in the hilt of the
godslayer to kill thanos
uh it didn't work in the infinity war
movie
he had three infinity stones so maybe it
might have worked if he didn't have the
stones
but either way it failed um but i would
say if this god slayer can kill
as guardians my assumption is that it's
made of uru
uh and was probably forged in nidavelir
that's like their big armory
in the mcu and that's where everyone
goes to get their weapons
and uru as we know from bjolnir loki's
fear of mjolnir
uh uru can kill an asgardian or someone
at that level
uh now thanos is not a celestial he's an
eternal with a deviant gene
uh but probably it looks like he could
not be killed with god slayer but he was
absolutely vulnerable to stormbreaker
that's how he got his head chopped off
in endgame
so using that logic godslayer is weaker
than stormbreaker
uh and when you know thor went to e tree
and unnativalia to ask for the one
weapon that could kill thanos ichiri's
like okay i got one that can do this
it's stormbreaker
so godslayer by comparison's not as
powerful and it probably could not kill
celestial to answer your question
uh so the one celestial we know who has
died
ego died in guardians vol 2. but uh the
celestial's
severed head that became nowhere that
celestia was killed by null
that's the uh symbiote klyntar god in
the comics yeah using all black the
necro sword
which that sword itself was like forged
using
some kind of because comics things like
the the shadow of null's evil spirit
the hivy so that's how that was able to
kill celestial and actually
interesting uh gore the god butcher
carries the necro sword so we might
actually see that
origin story in thor four from what
happened in nowhere but answer your
question
uh no a god slayer could not kill
uh celestial might be able to kill an
eternal
or an asgardian now i have a question
can you say
five times fast in thor four
she forges mjolnir of uru
in nitivelir that's a lot that's a lot
of words to say anything um
so in thor four she forges mjolnir and
nidovaliri zunuru and thor force uses
mjolnir to the
the nope and you got the order wrong i'm
sorry i'm ending this call
bye so if you want your rights back
and you want oklahoma to change be sure
and do that for me
but before i continue thank you to
displate for sponsoring this video
so displayed makes these high quality
art prints on metal
they have lots of great artist designs
from the worlds of gaming anime comics
check out some of my favorite marvel dc
and star wars displays using the link in
the description
so here's how it works they mount on
your wall with the help of a magnet
no tools needed no holes in the wall egg
that lets you easily rotate pieces in
and out so your zoom background can go
from a stylized stormtrooper helmet to
the poster for the
ragnarok in less time than it takes to
say hulk smash
display you can build collections of the
things you're passionate about right on
your wall
and this is great with every disc plate
that you buy you plant one tree through
displaced partnership with the
non-profit trees for the future
again you gotta check out some of my
favorite marvel dc star wars displays
and get your own
using the link in the description and
you get a special discount you'll be
supporting our channel and making some
major upgrades to your walls so click
that link and get your own display
hey we're back hello all right this next
question you should have it there
uh and it came with a special gift but
i'll just say real quick while you pull
that out
a simple question which wrestlers beside
john cena or the rock
i would make really good heroes or
villains in the mcu oh okay so this is
our friend
rich powers a great name sent us this
letter
and he also sent us these awesome uh
enamel pins that he makes
this is zombie iron man this is amazing
thanks dude
uh i'll be wearing this because if you
send me anything
i will wear it on camera this shirt was
also mailed to me by musician
christopher james who said you don't
have to promote me but i'm gonna do i'm
gonna give you a shout out because
you're a great musician and he sent me a
shirt
send me any shirts guys i don't want to
buy shirts anymore
uh so it could be a shirt you already
own that you just don't want to wear
anymore
i'll wear it i'll wash it i'll wear it
or that body condom from last week yeah
i'm currently wearing that it's
stretched so thin
uh wrestlers for the mcu i was doing
real good yeah i was styling out there
like a champion yeah
but guess who shows up for no reason at
all
okay interesting question because the
rock and john cena have both
um both kind of set an interesting
standard
for playing superheroes in the movies so
we have dave padista
uh was a wrestler and now he's like our
rmc wrestler
uh but the rock like refuses to lose in
movies
he refuses to ever play the bad guy and
he is still
slated to play black adam but he's going
to be probably like an anti-hero version
of black adam
um so it kind of limits our options of
how we could see these people
um but i would like to see brock lesnar
play
ben grimm the thing i think he i think
his body structure fits that and he
doesn't have to be a great actor
uh because he's gonna be covered in
rocks long as he looks like poop that's
all you really need
um yeah so that'd be i think a lot of
the other good roles are taken
i mean uh maybe aj styles his name or
that could be interesting
because he kind of looks like he could
be an underwater thing and i would say
roman reigns his name
but then people would compare him too
much to uh call drogo
uh aquaman so you need someone who kind
of looks different
oh yeah that's true next question yeah
dave sargent
uh has this one uh also sent you shoved
the letter there
uh okay yeah there you go uh if johnny
storm
loses his voice i love this question
does he
lose the ability to flame on uh thank
you for the dunder mifflin letterhead
here the people versus paper people
um okay so that's a very interesting
question
to answer your question dave it depends
on why
he lost his voice okay so if johnny
storm lost his voice by just screaming
himself horse at a concert
uh he could probably still just like
whisper or rasp flame on
and still like uh light up uh but
if the issue was he lost his voice as
uh it's either a symptom or a cause of
like lost confidence then
he might not be able to flame on because
in the comics whenever
johnny has like inner doubts or he's not
feeling confident he does temporarily
lose his abilities so he needs to be
confident the reason he says flame on is
to kind of just like
work himself up uh but it's not like the
flame powers
themselves are voice activated like an
alexa
or a siri or something it's he just kind
of says it as an explanation what if
like mcgruber like rips out his
vocal chords well then he might die at
that point
but like either way i bet he could slam
on as he goes
presumably if johnny storm was uh
mute or death he could sign
flame on and still flame off that makes
sense he could write it down
he could text it uh he could tweet flame
on
and he could flame on that's also how
you reverse a fart yeah
you tweet flame on a reminder that you
can help us go
even deeper down these dark paths by
becoming an official
uh patron uh and you can join us on
discord
at patreon.com new rockstars on there
you can submit questions but also i want
to challenge you guys to ask a question
that's really going to put eric on the
spot
uh i can't i can't be this bad
yes you can you could be worse well you
can get audio versions of this show by
subscribing to new rockstars
on wherever you get your podcast the big
question is the name of the show
uh thanks to everyone who submitted
questions this week especially those who
mailed stuff
in we we love doing it we love getting
mail from you guys
uh you can send in mail at our po box
address listed down below and send us
questions on twitter
everywhere uh by using the hashtag
bigquestion you can follow me at eavos
follow phillip at philip molina and you
can follow new rockstars on social media
and subscribe here on youtube
to get much more information on uh all
the stuff
you care about even uh the horrifying
crimes that people commit that you don't
want to think about
yeah tell us in the comments what crimes
you've gotten away with yeah and your
home address and name
all right see you guys next week
[Music]
do